Suppose there's a company called Bull Flag Cycling.
This company makes bikes.
Really good bikes.
The bikes are so good in fact, the company wants to expand...
...so it can sell more bikes to people all around the world.
To do this, the company needs to raise money, also known as capital.
There a few ways this company could do this.
They could take out a loan.
But that would mean taking on a significant amount of debt.
Or it could issue shares of stock.
By issuing stock, which is called going public,...
...the company can raise money without going into debt.
Instead, it sells shares of ownership and a claim on future earnings to investors.